hi everyone
welcome to today's live broadcast where
we're going to be talking
about maximizing capacity the impact of
technology
innovations and change management on
microbiology labs
my name is rachel shea i'm the associate
marketing director for bd keystroke
solutions for the
for the us region and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's webinar is brought to you by lab
roots and it has been sponsored by
beatty
for more information about bd please
visit our website at bd.com
so i just want to remind everybody
before we get started that today's event
is
interactive and we do encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and as you have
any time during the presentation to do
so you just type them into the ask the
question box and then
click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window and you can report
your question by clicking on the ask a
question box as well located on the far
left of your screen
i'd like to introduce the presenters for
today's webinar
i'm dr erin mcelvania is the director of
clinical microbiology at north shore
university health system
dr patrick murray is our vp of worldwide
scientific affairs at bd life sciences
and chrismarianic is one of our lean
health care consultants
for our integrated diagnostic solutions
platform
we're very excited to bring you this
session and we without any further ado
i'm going to bring on the first
presenter dr murray
very much it's a pleasure to
to be here what i'm going to discuss
is some of the microbiology trends the
impact of technology innovation
and change management i'm going to put
this in the perspective
of during the pandemic that we're
confronted with
so let me move to the next slide and
this this slide actually is very
interesting because we made this about a
week ago
and this is the experience with the sars
coronavirus 2 pandemic in the united
states and
at that time one week ago there was 231
000 deaths
related to this this pandemic
i mentioned that because every day in
the last
week we've approached two thousand
deaths a day
so now this number in one week has grown
to over two hundred and fifty thousand
likewise when we look at the number of
cases that were confirmed one week ago
is
9.4 million cases and today
it's it's look at the exact number it's
11.6 million
so we have 2 million additional cases in
one week
which emphasizes how rapidly this
pandemic is
is changing let me
go to our next slide and as we think
about the impact the pandemic on the
microbiology laboratory specifically
there's a number of things that we've
seen an increase we've seen the
development
and the performance of diagnostic test
for this pandemic
we've seen an increased demand for swabs
transport
media and testing reagents and we've
seen an increase in molecular testing
not just for the coronavirus but also
for other
respiratory pathogens and finally
there's an
increased demand in our technical staff
to perform increased numbers of tests
that are being ordered and to provide
those results in a very rapid
time period we also in the laboratory
have seen a decrease we've seen a
decrease in the more traditional
microbiology
tests that we do ones for bacteria for
fungi
and for mycobacteria so the composition
of the
microbiology laboratory in the last year
has changed very dramatically
now what i would like to do is is
also put this in perspective that means
that the microbiology laboratory must
reorganize itself
to accommodate more work a different
type of work
and to do that in a more efficient way
and so this requires the laboratory to
look
inward and to try to say how can we do a
better job
and so there's been a number of
approaches manual approaches or more
traditional approaches
to improving the efficiency of the
laboratory
and over the next two slides what i'll
do is give some examples of what those
improvements might look like
so if we first start with specimen
processing
what we see is that there's as the
bottles come into the laboratory they're
recessioned in the laboratory
receiving area we get a collection of
the bottles and then we stand up walk
over to an instrument and put the
bottles into the
blood culture incubator we also see that
as specimens come into the laboratory we
batch
processing those specimens and make it
more efficient
we delay in many times unless an
incubator is right in the receiving area
we delay incubating those plates after
they've been inoculated and so they may
sit
at room temperature in the processing
area
for a number of minutes or maybe even a
few hours before we take them into the
incubator
we have dedicated individuals that do
specialty tests such as gram stains
because it's more efficient
if one person does that versus having
multiple people
prepare the gram stains and interpret
those results
we also might have a dedicated
individual that hands incoming phone
calls
or discussions with physicians about the
tests that they've ordered
and finally we typically will process
specimens
during high volume periods of time where
we can keep our technologists busy
but in the off hours such as in the
evening or at night time
where there's not very much work to be
done those specimens may sit for
a number of hours before they're
actually processed for
uh for the incubation that's in the
processing area if we look at how we
actually
process the cultures we do the same
types of things
we will frequently in the morning go to
the incubator
take out the plates that we're going to
be working with put them at the
desk where the technologist works
and they may sit there for a number of
hours before they're actually processed
lost that's sorry
there um we also
will batch process a number of specimens
such as a positive blood culture
we'll wait until they're pro wait until
the cultures are
available when they're positive
we may not take them out as they come as
they become positive rather we may wait
until we have
four or five or six cultures take those
out and then we'll do batch
processing of those cultures such as
performing a gram stain
and identification or susceptibility
testing
we have dedicated deaths to process
different types of specimens so it's not
uncommon to have a blood culture desk i
have a urine culture desk
have a respiratory culture desk and so
forth
we will culture the plates i'm sorry
i've already mentioned that
where we leave them on the desk we can
we frequently organize our work
based on priorities so we may process
all of the specimens from the icu
patients first
and then process the other types of
specimens after that
we typically will organize our
identification and susceptibility
testing to perform that by
by batches so we may read all of our
urine plates
indicate what colonies we want to
identify
and then once we've sorted the negative
plates from the positive plates will go
back to those positive plates
select the colonies for identification
and then
later perform the susceptibility testing
and then finally we frequently only
perform work
on a primary shift and not be doing the
same types of processing
in the evening in the at nighttime or on
the weekends
and so the work that's performed in the
laboratory
is done a pull as to maximize the
efficiency
of the laboratory's processes now let me
explore that a little bit more this was
a study that was reported
from europe where they looked at over
200 laboratories in 25 european
countries
and it looked at how they processed
blood cultures and what they found was
that
in 42 of the laboratories
they they incubated the bottles upon
receipt 24 hours a day seven days a week
in other words in more than half of the
laboratories we'd have bottles that
frequently
would sit for many hours before they
were placed into the incubator
when you look at processing the positive
cultures only 13
of the laboratories would process those
cultures immediately
for the vast majority then they would
sit in the incubator until at some point
they were removed
and processed in batches 15
of the laboratories didn't process the
blood cultures the positive blood
cultures
on sundays or holidays and finally fewer
than 5
reported results 24 hours a day
seven days a week so again significant
delays
and reporting and processing and
reporting
what we would consider the most
significant specimens received in the
laboratory
this is a separate study that was
performed in the united states and what
we did is we looked at 13 hospitals
over an 18-month period of time and we
looked at how they processed the
positive
how they processed blood cultures there
is 165
000 blood cultures received during this
18 month period
and over 15 000 positive cultures
what we observed was that on average
between the time the specimens was
collected until the gram stain was
performed
there is a 20.4 hour
period of time if you think about it
on average it takes between 10 and 13
hours
for an organism to grow in the pot in a
blood culture bottle
in it this thing keeps jumping ahead for
me um
between 10 and 13 hours for an organism
to grow in a bottle so there's roughly
an
eight to ten hour delay that we observed
with this uh
with this study the time from when it
was collected
until we had an um identification of an
organism
was an additional 24 hours and for
susceptibility tests
it was a further additional 24 hours so
one day to do an identification when
today we have multi-top they can
identify
organisms in less than an hour from a
positive blood culture
and two days to get a susceptibility
test result
and again we have systems that allow you
to have results in 8 to 12 hours
so why are there these delays as we look
at this more critically
what we found was that and we'll focus
first on the upper left-hand
graph and you see four bars
and those are when the blood cultures
were collected
and what you see is that it's divided up
in six hour increments so the first bar
is between midnight to six in the
morning
the second bar is from six in the
morning till noon
the third bar is from noon to six in the
afternoon
and the last bar is from six in the
afternoon to midnight
you see that bottles are are collected
throughout the day night and evening um
and you see this
this distribution here with the majority
of the bottles
collected between say six and uh in the
morning and six
in in the afternoon now if all things
were
perfect you would see a similar
distribution for the gram stain for the
identification
and for the susceptibility test the time
periods would shift
but the distribution would look the same
in fact that's not the case when you
look at gram stains
and we look at the lower right hand box
you see about 50 percent of the gram
stains were reported
between six in the morning and noon
even more startling when you look at the
reports for identification in the upper
left hand box or for susceptibility
tests in the lower
right i'm sorry lower right hand box
what you see is the majority of the
tests over 80 percent
are reported between six in the morning
and noon
more appropriate more relevant if we
look at a very small time interval
the vast majority these are reported
between 8 in the morning
and 10 in the morning in other words the
microbiology laboratory organizes its
work based on its convenience not when
the
results should be reported or could be
reported
now if we look at a different way to
improve efficiency and think about
automation there's some things that we
can do
you can instead of having a significant
delay in getting the blood culture
bottles to the laboratory and put into
an incubator
you can put the incubator where the
cultures are collected
the majority of the cultures are
collected in the emergency department
or in the icu so there's an opportunity
to eliminate the
significant delays in transport by
just simply placement of an incubator in
the area where the
cultures are being collected with
automation you can process specimens as
they arrive in the laboratory they don't
have to be batched
there's not a need for that you can get
improved and consistent plate streaking
with automation which decreases the
number of subcultures that are required
which will increase or which will
decrease the
delays in getting results getting
specimens processed
because they the automated systems have
track bases
track based systems that allow you to
move the plates from inoculation
to incubators you eliminate the delay
and incubation
and then you have now because of
automation and processing
you have reduced staffing needs so the
staff now can be doing other things such
as
making telephone calls or doing or
performing
specialty tests and then finally
processing can be automated so skilled
technologists
aren't required 24 hours a day seven
days a week
so this allows to have processing
throughout all
shifts in the laboratory
just to give a couple of examples of the
impact of this if we think about
streaking
and we look at a zigzag pattern of
automated streaking versus manual
streaking
this was a study that looked at the
impact with
screening plates for mrsa and cre
and what they found was that the number
of subcultures required
were significantly reduced with the
automated zigzag pattern as streaking
they also found that the time to results
was significantly reduced
with this because there were fewer
subcultures that were required
as we think about then automation is a
way to improve processing we also have
to think about its impact
on processing cultures and what you see
is that there's a decreased staffing
demands
so that the potential for on-demand
processing of positive blood cultures
that is the immediate removal of the
bottles from the incubator
the due performance of the gram stain
the identification susceptibility
testing
becomes much more feasible because you
now have additional technologists
available
to do these types of processes we also
because you
leave the plates in the incubator it's
if they're immediately incubated
and they're not removed from the
incubator during the
workup of those cultures you have faster
growth in this constant
incubation temperature and so you can
see
earlier time to when you have
significant growth where you can do your
identification
and your susceptibility testing and you
can also
automate this process of selecting
colonies
and processing those colonies for
identification
and for susceptibility testing and then
finally
we have analytics that allow us to guide
how the staff is work working
where staffing is available to help
other
members of the staff with their
processing and so we're able to run a
much more efficient laboratory
with the access of these types of
analytics
just a couple of uh example i'll use one
example here
just to illustrate the
it looks like we've lost um looks like
we've lost
the doctor murray um
so let me just jump in um and if i could
just get some verification in the chat
that you can hear me
not sure if it's us
in any case um yeah my name is uh my
name is chris renick my name
uh uh or my uh my role with bd is uh as
a lean healthcare consultant
and one of the um one of the things that
uh that we like to do is we
we like to provide um uh like to provide
services to
to lab automation customers um it's
essentially
um not just providing you with an
instrument with a piece of technology
the technology is very
important um let's not kill ourselves
about that
but really what we're here to do is is
provide the value
and maximize the value of the uh the
automation technology to the lab
um what um uh what we try and do
is really really just create a uh
a suite of services uh when uh when you
purchase bd
automated technology it's not just about
the install that's the project
management side the physical and
and um the you know the logistical side
of that
but um more importantly is the change
management part which dr mclevenia is
going to talk about after i'm done
and then the the workflow analysis that
um that we provide to
uh to the lab staff and and to
uh to to hospital leadership to
understand exactly how that technology
um uh is is best used and and what the
impact is uh both on the lab staff
the the wider hospital and and um and
ultimately the patient
right so what we wanted to do was really
just um
uh you know sort of just to disambiguate
um when we talk about lean um we're not
just talking about um
about cutting head count that's that's
really not the goal of of any of what we
do we're not
you know there to compare one shift to
another or just to strictly say okay
here's what the impact of
our technology is um and here's how it
it will impact you know the the
economics of
of your lab that's all important and
again we're not we're not dismissing
that
what we try and do is take an approach
uh you know sort of a
partner approach with uh with bd
customers and keystroke customers
in order to understand lab activity um
and the capability of the staff
working there but also um also
you know to leverage the uh i guess the
repeatability that
automation offers in order to
standardize work that human element of
work that's involved in uh
in in automating and then really just
increasing the value um of uh
of of the the uh the value created for
the patient and for the
for the health system of the lab effort
um
we have people that that work in labs
uh you know 24 hours processing
specimens
um a lot of that a lot of that
repetitive work can be taken away
and you know we can leverage that that
knowledge aspect and you know that
decision making
aspect that uh that that they do offer
on a uh
in in the lab so when
you know one of the first things that we
look at is is productivity
right so just to define productivity and
for any of you engineers out there
there's
uh there's an equation there but really
simply put
productivity is just the units of
production over um
the units of input right um and it's
it's really meant as a high level
assessment of
where uh you know how productive we are
and
and how much work we can accomplish with
the given
input resources right so one of the
things that we
typically look at prior to automation is
something we call the lpi the lab
productivity index
um a lot of there's there's a lot of uh
misunderstanding about the lab
productivity index what it is what it
isn't
it's not uh it's not a judgment of where
your lab stands relative to others
it's a valid comparator but it's always
always got to be placed in context right
so what
what we use it for is really just to
measure
and assess the impact of automation on
the overall productivity of the lab
so when we take a look at at your lab
prior to automation we'll try and assess
lpi um and the lpi
uh impact of automation before and after
by measuring the specimens processed in
scope so so anything that that
we think that you know eventually we can
process with keystroke automation
and taking a look at the the overall um
the overall
lab staff uh you know the available um
the available
technologist labor in in the uh in the
the lab and what that allows us to do is
is
really create sort of a baseline
measurement it doesn't tell us all of
the
all of the issues it doesn't identify
root causes what it does
is really just give us sort of a
baseline to
to compare progress to right so we're
going to talk about three
sites that that we've um that we've
engaged
um in you know in our um uh in in the
last
couple of years in automating now all of
these three
sites sort of started from the same
place um if you look at the overall
landscape
volume and again we're not talking about
uh when we're talking about in-scope
volume
obviously we're not talking about
chemistry we're just talking about
micro specimens that are destined for um
or or able to be processed uh on
keystroke lab automation
so we're looking at you know volumes of
anywhere between 425 or 375 rather
to about 450 that's all in the same
ballpark right um
and the reason we're showing you this is
not necessarily to talk about the
the details of these three labs it's
just to sort of
uh you know to to gauge them one against
another we're not talking about a
massive reference
laboratory that's processing thousands
of specimens a day
these are three sites in in you know
with three different
population uh centers um and
you know three different um uh really
sets of circumstances but from uh let's
say a very high level
so again that lpi level that that number
of specimens processed on a peak day
and they're relatively the same but one
of the things that
you know we we identified prior to this
and and you know
in engaging the customers the level of
staff engagement
the level of leadership support
and that disposition to to to change
right change management is something dr
mclemania will talk about in a little
bit but
um all of those for what we call site
one
um were relatively low right um whereas
the other two sites were a lot more
engaged they were a lot uh they were in
a better position let's say
to to manage that change and to manage
the processes involved
in uh in lab automation and what we saw
um and you'll see that on the next slide
is
the difference that that outcome has in
in um in overall lab productivity right
so if we look at you know site one where
we said
you know the level of engagement that
resistance to change
was was higher staff was less engaged
leadership was
sort of less willing to to really adapt
the way they were
uh the way they were working um and
really trying to hold on to that
that uh you know that pre-automation
sort of uh
paradigm um you see them starting at a
level of
uh at an lpi of around 17 and going up
to
48.8 by any definition
that's an amazing increase in
productivity right that
that there is is really you know the
selling feature of the technology in and
of itself it's just saying look if you
really do
um uh if if you really adopt automation
it's going to
increase your productivity it's going to
take away some of the repetitive
and the let's say the the more
mechanical aspects
of of the work in the lab
[Music]
so that your staff can really focus on
the analytical and the the you know the
the intelligence side of of
what we do in a lab um but when you
compare it to the other two staff
or the other two labs where staff was
more apt to change
where you know as a team they were more
willing to adapt standard ways of
working
um sharing work right lowering batch
sizes
you know moving towards that ideal of of
one patient at a time treatment um you
know
you see that there's a significant
increase um and a significantly
better improvement in in that overall
lab productivity
and really that's all we're saying is
not that not not saying that you know
these three labs are identical and
what you know what was done in site one
should should uh
should be a a warning sign it's really
just here's the opportunity right the
opportunity is
one let's use that automation as a
platform for
um for you know a larger change in um in
in the way we process uh specimens in
the lab and the way we deal with
patients
as they present themselves at the lab in
the form of a specimen
um and and change the way that uh that
that we work
change the workflow change the way that
uh that we distribute work and share
work
from uh from one uh one bench to another
but also from
you know from across shifts and that
sort of thing
and you know one of the things that that
uh keestra technology allows us to do
and this is just one very simple example
is um
just you know the the the level of
information that we have
because of the fact that all of our
engagement with specimens
um with automated specimens is recorded
it allows us
you know in in great def detail and
specificity to take a look at
you know what are some of those metrics
in this case this is just an example
this is not meant to be indicative of of
uh you know
where uh where your lab ought to be it's
just really saying
here's what we're able to do is is to
say that okay well
you know the the site that we refer to
as site one um
you know their reads per plate and the
the number of times that they were
looking at a particular
uh plate um once it was incubated is
significantly higher than the other two
and
what we realized afterwards in digging
into the that process is
is um you know there was there were some
some elements of the of the population
the specimen types that
contributed to that but in a lot of
cases it was the way they distributed
their samples the way that they they
approached cross training
and staffing on different um different
benches
and you know we were able to coach them
uh coach them towards
an improved situation and improved
current state where
you know that that gap is significantly
lower than what you see here
right um and and really that's that's
the the benefit that we're trying to
demonstrate is
how do we get um how do we you know
leverage technology how do we change the
workflow and change the way we engage
with that automation technology in the
lab
and use the informatics that keestra
allows us
allows us to to pull how do we use that
to really improve
and continuously sort of go back to the
process and and
continue to engage staff to change and
improve the way that we're
working on things so you know one of the
words i've been using a lot has been
change
right and that that psychological aspect
of
changing the way we work um i i'm going
to hand it over to
dr aaron mclemania um and she'll talk to
you about uh
about the the change management in that
human and psychological
management aspect of actually adopting
um
adopting technology uh and and keystroke
technology and automation in the lab
at north shore so go ahead dr aaron
hello and um i want to thank bd for
asking me to speak to you today and i'm
really excited to talk about something
i'm passionate about which is total
laboratory automation
and also just what happens to an actual
lab when you undergo
uh this huge transition
so just for um i guess to baseline you
i wanted to introduce my hospital system
where i'm at so north shore university
health system
is located in the north chicago suburbs
and you can see
on this map here each one of these dots
is a
hospital we have we have four legacy
hospitals that our microbiology lab
currently serves
plus we have recently acquired two
additional hospitals
and are in talks about bringing that
work into microbiology possibly
we also have a large outpatient reach
with
over 25 immediate cares over 100
physician offices and
all of the microbiology for the whole
system is centralized in evanston
illinois
and just also baseline you we do about
344
billable tests uh that's for last year
this year you know remains to be seen
so i wanted to show you our lab
before we got keystroke tla and you can
see that it looks like you know a very
normal microbiology lab but very
cluttered a lot of things in a small
space
and we really it was important for us to
stay in the same space we really liked
where we're located in the hospital
um and the access it gave it to it gave
us
um to our physicians so for that reason
we wanted to
stay and this is kind of what we look
like during our physical transformation
to keestra
and this is what we look like afterwards
so standing in the same
the same spot in the picture in the left
you can see how open
and decluttered and just um i always say
it's a little bit zen which is is odd
for microbiology lab
but those are the physical changes and
what i think everyone understands when
they get tla
there's going to be a big physical
change in the lab but i don't think
everyone recognizes that there are
a lot of culture changes as well and i
think those are
just as important as physically getting
the keystra
to be able to use it to its maximum
capacity
so um the workflow change is that before
keystroke tla we had very defined bench
besides dr marie mentioned you got your
urine bench your respiratory bench etc
um and at the beginning of the day you
go to the incubator you get your plates
for that bench you're working you set
them down you start working through them
you know work till lunch put them away
bring them back out work in the
afternoon you know at the beginning of
the day exactly what you have and those
are
your cultures and you are manually
viewing all of those auger plates
so the big change for us is when we got
keister tla we moved from
individual specimen benches to a model
that's collective
and consists of a reader bench and a
worker bench
so what that consists of as you can see
here
um this is our reader bench it is not
connected to our
tla system it could be anywhere in the
lab in the hospital
on a beach et cetera after covet um
so what happens at this bench is you can
see our wonderful technologist barb here
she's viewing
our uh lis system our our
internal laboratory information system
on the left and
keystroke plates on the plate images on
the
on the right and um she's going to read
through these plates and
uh decide you know do something need
further work up
is there no growth is it mixed and she's
going to do
all of that by viewing the plates on the
computer and not handling
physically handling any of the plates
and so for this whole time
the keystroke plates are being read
they're in the incubator
warm nice co2 concentration
happily growing bacteria as quickly as
possible
um and so for this we it is really
collaborative reading of cultures
because
you have all the cultures that need to
be read that day are on a common work
list and then
all the people signed to the reader
bench are just going to work through
those
uh through the course of the day now
uh in contrast and then we have our
worker bench and so
these are the benches that are attached
to our keystroke tla system
which is to the left of what another one
of our wonderful technologists adil
and here plates are going to anything
that needs to be worked up is going to
be handled on this bench if you need a
catalase if you
need to perform moldy toff mass
spectrometry identification
you need susceptibility testing anything
where you physically handle those plates
they're going to be pulled out of the
incubator and delivered to the bench
by a track so the technologists not have
to get up and go find them
and again you're only pulling out the
plates you absolutely need you don't
pull out all the plates associated with
a culture um and so this
also just maximizes the time those
plates are in the incubator it also
decreases a lot of clutter because
you're only pulling plates out for
a few minutes and then putting them back
on the track so they go back into the
incubator
so as you can see with this method
instead of these plates
are these plates are mine and i am going
to
work on them till i'm done at the end of
the day
it's a more of a change to no one is
done till everyone is done all the
cultures are collectively owned
uh they are they are red and worked up
in in a i wanna say a random fashion but
they they really do belong to everyone
and so this is really nice because it
establishes a protocol it keeps us on
our protocols because at least two sets
of ice are in each
culture both the readers and the workers
and it also
that results in strict adherence to
labrador
laboratory protocols
there you go um and it also allows for a
lot of flexibility between the readers
and the workers to really
optimize that productivity on the
specimen workload so my example is
always
that if you come in early and you happen
to be on a worker bench and there's no
work for you to do
it doesn't matter you can easily move
back and forth between the benches and
so you will
take up a reading uh you will take up
the reader bench and read a few cultures
to make some work
uh for yourself and then as your
colleagues trickle in um
if you're the first person in the
morning then you will
be able to make make that work and um
and then at the end of the day kind of
conversely that the people will
have more work to do because all the
cultures have been read and so they will
help out with
testing and susceptibility things like
that on the um
on the worker bench so this really
allows for
better staffing efficiency what you can
do with this system with the readers and
the workers is you can really look at
when your specimens arrive to the lab
and how can i optimize both
my staffing um work times and then also
my reading times
uh how long a plate is incubated before
you take an image of it based on the
type of specimen it is and also
um your your volumes and your arrival
times
and we have this all tracked on a nice
dashboard
and so that you can look at the
dashboard you can come in in the morning
you see how many
cultures need to be read and the
breakdown of what kind of specimens they
are you start your most important
specimens like your blood csf
and kind of move along throughout the
day and you can even base
what is going on in the afternoon say
but you know how many cultures are
coming up to be ready so you can
plan around that
okay so change management is change is
is difficult i don't want to say that
it's not and uh how does staff
actually respond to such a drastic
culture change
and the answer is there's not one answer
like people uh it is variable we
there are definitely going to be some
staff some
staff who are just not interested in
going on this journey and may
go to different areas of the lab we have
some staff that
adapt very very quickly um and then we
have
all kinds of staff in the middle and um
so you know it's a range for sure so
what can you do to
make this culture change better one
thing i would say
is very careful selection of a key user
group
so this is our key user group here from
uh when we went live
with tla and what they what they are
going to be is your champions of
automation
they are um going to get you through
this process and they are going to bring
the rest of the staff along with them
they are going to they're going to need
to have a positive
attitude and really believe in
automation
as the future for for this to work out
and so in our group we picked
a variety of people from all three
shifts so that every shift was
was represented and um then you know
they're
they're able to um help along that
that journey with with everyone involved
you also need really strong leadership
there will be some hard days i am not
going to lie
and so for that reason you need a lab
director you need
administration you need everyone
involved to really believe that this is
the future and kind of have the attitude
going forward
we we can't get bogged down in little
things we have to
make sure we're moving forward and
optimizing for the future
so what i i think was
most useful for us in surviving this
culture change
is really communicating a lot with your
technologist
so i say that although um you know i
i hear a lot more from administration
and the physicians
um being a laboratory director my
technologists are in constant
communication with each other
they see the calls coming in that
they're getting they notice
uh they notice areas for improvement
definitely and many processes that
i'm just not going to pick up so we have
constant communication about
areas where we can improve
we also you've got to embrace a lot of
creative ideas and i have to say some of
the best things that have come out of
this have been
ideas that are some of our technologists
had how we could do things
a little bit differently than we had
before and they ended up being
very efficient and and it worked very
well for everyone
and i really do think it's the
participation of everyone involved
in the whole automation process that
leads to ownership of the process and
then acceptance because it's not
something else that someone's forcing on
them it's their process
it's they're they're responsible for
making it be it the best it can be
and so although you know at this point
when we when we first got our tla
i will say that you know there were a
lot of things to work out because we
were the first one in the nation and so
we were working together with bd to get
a lot of things ironed out
and now we're pretty much set in our
protocols but that doesn't mean we're
done it's
it's it's just like all laboratory
protocols you're always looking for
gains in efficiency
little tweaks that you can make to make
things easier on the lab to shave a few
a little bit off your turnaround time
and then we're constantly adapting
because even
um you know outside the lab is evident
with covet 19 there's a lot going on
and you have to adapt to those changes
so for example
our career schedule got changed had a
drastic redo a few years ago
and then that caused us to look at all
of our
what our specimens were coming into our
lab and kind of reassess the the best
times for our cultures and our staffing
hours
so we know that there is a huge staffing
shortage in microbiology
uh this is from 2015 um
but things have not gotten better since
then and
we also know that there's a high rate of
anticipated retirement so
um i think only all laboratories know
this but now it's kind of becoming
evident to the rest of the world that
that laboratory medicine staffing is
something that is of great concern
so what can you do to
make the staff you know to minimize
those shorting step
staffing shortages well i would say that
automation
definitely would be one thing that i
would do if i didn't already have it
so um i wanted to look a little bit uh
so i looked into a little bit of return
on investment you know how are we doing
with with our keystroke tlight now
we've had it in use for about five years
we went live in december 2014
so i guess it's almost six years and at
that time we had about
uh 26 uh full-time employees
uh full-time equivalents probably a few
more employees so in the
in the past five years since we've had
keestra our volumes uh before coped had
they had grown by 21
um and currently we have 21 and a half
uh full-time fp so that shows that we
are
doing a lot more you know we're handling
a lot more volume
with less people so this is just a
picture today this is a typical day
staff that we have in my lab and
actually there are three
uh med tech students in there as well so
we're pretty
pretty lean um so
looking at our volumes and with that 21
increase
we would have needed if we were doing
you know our pre-covered
uh or sorry our prehistoric um
we had our pre-keystroke setup our plate
reading
our lab we would need 31 and a half fpe
to handle that increased workload and i
know i showed you pictures at the
beginning
but there was not room for an additional
five or six
uh full-time employees in that space we
were very crowded
uh before kistra was implemented um
so that 10 extra fps would cost our
department this is conservatively way
over
quarter three quarters of a million
dollars a year we also would not fit in
our current laboratory space as i said
so we'd have to look at you know are we
going to
move what are we going to do there is no
additional space in the hospital so it
would have been very costly
and then we could never have entertained
adding
the workload of two additional hospitals
onto
our current um onto our current volumes
without automation
and that is just what we can measure in
the lab there are a lot of financial
benefits that
are indirectly um you know indirectly
related to the lab and therefore they're
a little bit difficult to assign costs
but
we're definitely using fewer laboratory
supplies we're doing your subcultures
fewer loops
fewer you know just a lot fewer things
in the lab for our patients they're more
rapid
hospital discharges we believe based on
the rapid nature of which we're getting
our identification susceptibility
results out to physicians
and then also using fewer antibiotics
and fewer doses of antibiotics which
are very expensive as well so but
the benefits go outside of the lab but
those can be a little bit more difficult
to quantify
so in conclusion i just want to say the
implementation of ddkystra every
it requires a completely different
workflow than traditional microbiology
but i really think it's worth making the
change because
just dropping as crest showed just
dropping the keystra
in a lab does make it somewhat more
efficient but if you're able to
change the culture of the lab and really
optimize you're able to
increase that efficiency dramatically
change management is challenging but
with strong leadership both from
i would say all the way from the top
administration lab administration
laboratory directors and uh staff
and the technologists um you can get
through it and like i said
definitely worth worth the uh
worth the pain to go through and
um the return on investment really is
there for tla
you can see that just in the staffing
efficiencies alone
uh let alone other benefits to the
hospital
so with that like i said i just want to
thank bd for
asking me to speak today and i think we
will
move on to the q a portion of this
presentation
thank you dr maclevania um so
we do have some questions here um and i
just want to remind everyone who's on
the line
if you have a question that you would
like to ask just add it into the q a
the ask a question um chat box um so
the first question that i have here is
from cress
there's four crafts i should say so what
kind of workflow data is available
uh from the keister systems and how do
labs tend to use this in order to
improve
their processes
well first off what uh what keystra
allows us to do
um you know in the first generation with
uh with a daily report
and now with you know the upcoming
generation of of keystream synapses
it really allows us to take a detailed
look at
everything that happens on the actual
system
um with you know taking a look at
at uh in terms of what and you know
what's being processed um
the number of specimens uh
of of each different kind it allows us
to break that sort of thing down
and and really give us a picture of
what's actually coming through the lab
secondly it allows us to take a look at
the uh
you know we can pull information from
the system that allows us to to sort of
give us a life cycle of each and every
specimen to take a look at
when something was was inoculated when
it was incubated um
when was it followed up and what what
that sort of time that that cadence is
how long was something um you know how
long was a specimen
or or a plate ready for reading um and
when was it actually read
right so that's useful in in sort of
helping us compress that that delta t
and and really really you know stay on
top
of uh i guess just the the the mechanics
and the the day-to-day processes
uh that that happen in the lab um
it allows us to take a look at who is
doing what
and how long was was you know how much
effort
we're putting in in different areas of
um
of of the actual uh uh of that that
specimen life cycle
so really what it allows us to do is at
a very level
you know very detailed level it allows
us to analyze the
the you know the basic mechanics the the
operational efficiency of the lab of the
lab staff
and of the work that's going through it
and it allows us
it doesn't tell us how well we're doing
it really just
points us to to ask questions right so
you know
you know looking at one report and one
snapshot of a single day doesn't tell us
anything
if we don't follow and and you know do
that daily management aspect of uh
of of lab management so once we
once we see that something is sort of
you know off
um you know off the charts in terms of
either it's you know
a particular specimen type was was
uh was really either a lot slower than
or a lot faster than usual or
we spent a lot more time working up
specimens it allows us to follow up with
those questions right so again
it's not about the technology and what's
happening it's about how we use the
information that we get from the
technology
in order to make informed decisions
about the lab i hope that answers the
question
yeah i know that was perfect thank you
chris um
question here for dr mcelveen so for
hospitals our labs looking to understand
the financial impact of automation
outside of the lab
what approaches would you recommend that
they take a look at
um so
i guess what it what is the perspective
of
i guess of this question uh is it
someone looking to
bring in automation as you know for
administrators is it a lab director
is it i think it kind of depends but
it is very hard to capture costs outside
of the lab i will say
and so um although we've worked somewhat
um to find find the answer to this uh
you need really strong you need a really
strong data management system like your
electronic medical record to be able to
track you know everything that's going
on
so um you know it it's challenging
we know it's there we hear from our
colleagues we hear from pharmacy
that they appreciate having the
susceptibility testing
so quickly um i know when we went live
dr thompson who was here previously said
someone called the lab and said there
must be a mistake
we just sent this urine down and because
we had a read on it in 10 hours
like probably 10 and a half gotta do
some some testing but
we had to read so early that someone
thought we had a specimen mismatch that
was right before we went
live and we're like no no that's your
patient specimen like we have this new
system
and it's just very fast so we definitely
know
the impact does you know reach the
clinicians
and um but we we just don't always have
a great way to measure that
yeah i know that's very fair um so
another question here and maybe this is
one that um
uh you know i'll ask dr mcilvenia uh
first within crest maybe you can also
give sort of a
higher level perspective as well so um
it's more around
have we reviewed turnaround times from
collection to when it's the specimens
are received in the lab
um to um to timed results
before and after automation and what
kind of improvements were seen so
maybe doctor mcaveeney if you could give
the north shore perspective first that
would be great
um yes i mean for me i have to think
back because it's been a while since we
went through this
transition but um
definitely when we looked at our
turnaround time and i think
dr thompson did publish on this with
urines i mean we saw a dramatic decrease
in our turnaround time for urine
and then also because we were getting
the id sooner we're getting
susceptibility testing set up sooner so
even though susceptibility testing
itself was not shortened
we were starting the process sooner
therefore the final result was out
sooner so all the way around um
definitely
we are it has a huge impact we picked
urine because that's what we had the
most of and it's a very
uh it's probably one of our easiest
things to measure but this is affecting
all specimen types that we have
so the the the um thing that i'd add to
that
is is uh you know rachel you mentioned
that
delta t between turn around time uh or
the
between collection and result so that
actually requires us to look outside
outside the walls of the lab what we
found
is that that's sometimes a profound sort
of uh
mindset shift for a lot of labs
uh to really look at you know what
happens outside the lab it does require
us to
to monitor the data but typically what
we find
is that when you start monitoring
something
it does you know it does decrease um
not just magically it's because you know
when we start monitoring it
we actually make an effort to begin to
ask questions that's one of the powerful
things
about automation is the data that it
gives us allows us to
ask questions that will attack those
sorts of things
so turnaround time doesn't magically
decrease because we automate
um but you know there's a there's a
concerted effort
to uh to understand the system and the
process and that's something that
you know as as a healthcare consultant
with bd
we do help labs actually work towards
that
that um you know asking those questions
taking a look at the data and not just
saying well here's your scorecard
is what does that actually mean spending
time in the lab taking a look at what's
actually going on
and what does this metric mean how do we
you know how do we uh
how do we slightly change our behavior
in the lab
and and our workflow in order to maybe
reduce that time right reduce some of
those
some of those delays in between one step
um both
prior to um prior to automation and
afterwards one of the things that we're
looking at is is uh
mapping that out um uh you know from uh
that that's an ongoing initiative to
actually map out that that collection to
result um uh workflow but um but
yeah uh you know really the there is a
reduction there
it's it but again it's not uh it doesn't
just
happen because we uh we flick the switch
on the keystra has to be
managed and and it's important to stay
on top of that
yeah and i would just i i know we're
short on time i would just um
piggyback on chris's answer in that i
completely agree
um you know it allowed us to um
keister allowed us to really look at
what our specimens are coming in
when they're ready to be read and to see
if
we could change our staffing by just a
little bit to
be able to capture a large percentage of
those
organisms um whereas sometimes you know
if if a slight change in staffing
is only built in reading an extra three
percent of cultures that's not worth it
but
maybe an hour or two could get could um
get you
30 of cultures or 20 you know that would
be a staffing change you'd want to make
potentially and so i think it's really
good to be able to track that because
not all
shifts are you know created equally so
completely agree
great thanks so again as you mentioned
we're sort of at the the end of our time
so i just want to thank everybody we do
have more questions coming in um
um what i will do is i will provide the
questions
to the to the speakers and have them
provide a response
so that again don't feel like your
question won't get answered because i
think there's a lot of really critical
questions here obviously this is a
really interesting um topic
so again i wanted to thank our
presenters for joining us today
sharing their experiences and thank you
all for attending
we really appreciate your support
thank you for stopping
great thank you everyone